merci benoît pour cette actualité
l'actualité américaine s'est évidemment
l'élection présidentielle on est à mi
journée à peu près des votes des
américains deux préoccupations
essentielles dans des bals concerts
l'éducation et la santé quand on sait 44
millions d'américains n'ont pas de
couverture maladie sts dire un tiers de
plus qu'il y a dix ans on mesure toute
l'inquiétude que cela peut avoir dans
les milieux les plus démunis tenez quand
on va à l'hôpital vaut mieux avoir soit
sa carte d'assurance soit sa carte de
crédit et puis il ya une grosse
préoccupation basse et trouver des
médicaments moins chers que ceux qui
sont disponibles sur le territoire
américain voyez le reportage dans le
vermont d'isabelle bechler edouard perd
1,43 million d'américains n'ont pas
d'assurance maladie et bien des gens du
troisième âge ne sont pas remboursés
leurs médicaments comme leurs prix ne
cessent de grimper des gens comme
pauline 73 ans ne savent comment faire
face
bien que pas loin j'en suis à 4 180
francs par semaine pour des retraités à
revenu fixe on n'a pas vraiment à se
plaindre mais c'est dur d'avoir à mettre
tout le superflu dans l'achat de
médicaments
les personnes âgées vont peser dans
l'élection plus conservatrice elle
pourrait quand même voter démocrate pour
des raisons sociales on serait tenté de
voter démocrate al gore à la présidence
je vais me battre pour vous pour que
vous ayez de meilleurs remboursements
médicaux et ça pour toutes les personnes
âgées on va réduire les prix et se
battre plus d'égalité des soins
heureusement pour pauline son nouveau
médecin lui a proposé d'acheter ces
médicaments par correspondance au canada
voisin cette fois ci elle économisera
40% seulement les certaines molécules
jusqu'à treize fois plus cher aux états
unis
gore s'est engagé à mettre en place un
système de remboursement des médicaments
pour toutes les personnes âgées
je pense que le programme de boucher
plus limite
on va se baser sur un financement solide
et faire que toutes les personnes âgées
qui ont besoin puissent acheter leurs
médicaments
le programme du candidat républicain ne
prévoit cette couverture que dans quatre
à cinq ans et milite surtout pour une
assurance privée pauline pense que ce
sera trop tard pour elle et si son mari
tombe malade il on est obligé
d'économiser de manière absurde
le pire c'est quand les patients n'ose
pas me dire qu'ils ne prennent pas leurs
médicaments ils les prennent quelques
jours avant la consultation pour avoir
l'air en meilleure forme mais où il y a
des gens qui en sont là
pauline a eu le courage de parler à son
médecin mais préférerait une solution
nationale ceux qui n'osent pas la
nouvelle et tapageuse prospérité
américaine les laissera sur le bord du
chemin